bundeskanzler wir sehen den
ministerpräsidenten von nordrhein
westfalen und franziska giffey im
anschluss an die ich sag mal
voraussichtlich letzte
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz des jahres
ich darf begrüßen bundeskanzler olaf
scholz den nordrhein westfälischen
ministerpräsidenten henrik wüst und die
frischgebackene berliner regierende
bürgermeisterin franziska gefallen herr
scholz fängt an
meine damen und herren heute hat sich
die bundesregierung mit den
ministerpräsidenten und
ministerpräsidenten der 16 länder
getroffen bevor ich aber zu den inhalten
unseres treffens komme möchte ich heute
der neu gewählten regierenden
bürgermeisterin von berlin franziska
giffey einen herzlichen glückwunsch sein
wie ist die zeitläufe wollen ist sie nun
gleich am tag ihrer wahl als co
vorsitzender der konferenz der
ministerpräsidenten und
ministerpräsidenten gefordert gewesen
daher freue ich mich dass sie nun mit
herrn wüst und mir zusammen über die
heutigen beratung berichten kann
ziel unserer und erregung unterredung
mit dem ministerpräsident und
ministerpräsident war ist unser land auf
die bevorstehende nächste corona welle
vorzubereiten
ich bin froh dass der von uns
eingesetzte expertenrat am wochenende
eine so klare und im übrigen einhellige
einschätzung zur omikron abgegeben hat
ich danke an dieser stelle den
wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern und all den übrigen
experten für diese wichtige arbeit
ihre wissenschaftliche einschätzung ist
die grundlage für die politischen
entscheidungen die wir jetzt treffen
und ich bin dankbar dass wir so zügig im
kreis der 16 länder und der
bundesregierung zusammengekommen sind um
zu besprechen welche maßnahmen zu
ergreifen sind damit unser land und
durch die nächste zeit kommt
lassen sie mich noch eines vorweg sagen
ich kann jeden und jede verstehen die
nichts mehr hören will von corona von
mutationen und neuen virus maria doch
wir können dürfen nicht die augen
verschließen wo dieser nächsten welle
die sich vor uns aufzutun beginnt
im augenblick befinden wir uns noch in
einer seltsamen zwischenzeit die
maßnahmen auf die wir uns ende november
verständigt haben würden überall und
flächendeckend gehen die
infektionszahlen deutlich zurück wir uns
das robert koch institut meldet ganz
allmählich verringert sich sogar auch
die belegung der intensivstation etwas
auch wenn die belastung der
beschäftigten weiteren sehr groß ist und
wir in einzelnen regionen an der grenze
sind
das zeigt dass unsere strengen maßnahmen
seit ende november die erwünschte
wirkung zeigen die strikten
zugangsbeschränkung für ungeimpfte der
zusätzliche schutz durch test um sowie
die starke booster kampagne der
vergangenen wochen waren richtig
willkommen die vierte welle also langsam
im griff
das wäre eigentlich eine gute nachricht
eigentlich denn diese pandemie lehrt uns
so schnell wie erhofft ist es nicht
vorbei es droht nun bereits die welle 5
in großbritannien dänemark und auch in
den usa ist omikron bereits auf dem
vormarsch
diese variante des virus unterscheidet
sich in nicht unwesentlichen merkmalen
von denen zuvor sie ist nach
einschätzung der fachleute was die
infektionen betrifft noch aggressiver
und sind eigenschaften die es
ermöglichen den impfschutz stellenweise
zu unterlaufen selbst zweifach geimpfte
und auch genesene laufen hohe gefahr
sich mit dieser variante anzustecken
erst eine frische bußtag eine
auffrischungsimpfung bietet einigermaßen
schutz gegen eine infektion
omikron ist leichter ansteckend
verbreitet sich schneller und wird die
zahl der infektionen in den kommenden
wochen massiv ansteigen
darauf müssen wir uns jetzt einstellen
deshalb haben wir uns heute mit den 16
ministerpräsidenten und
ministerpräsidenten getroffen
noch ist omikron in deutschland nicht
flächendeckend aufgetreten aber
es ist nach derzeitiger einschätzung
bestenfalls nur eine frage von wenigen
wochen ist diese virusvariante sich auch
bei uns durchsetzen wird
deshalb müssen wir uns auch jetzt darauf
vorbereiten
wir folgen dabei den ratschlägen des
wissenschaftlichen experten gremiums
bevor ich zu den einzelnen maßnahmen
komme noch ein wort zum zeitpunkt von
dem die neuen maßnahmen an gelten sollen
wir haben bewusst entschieden soweit sie
nicht vor ort schon irgendwo eingeführt
sind sie erst nach weihnachten anlaufen
zu lassen die erfahrungen der
vergangenen beiden jahre haben gezeigt
dass weihnachten und ostern
auch durch die
verhaltensweise der bürgerinnen bürger
sich nicht als große pandemie treiber
erwiesen haben im gegenteil die ferien
haben die infektionszahlen bürger oft
verringert die familien scheint
verantwortungsvoll und vorsichtig mit
diesen festtagen umzugehen im
beschränkten rahmen mit ausreichend
testung und der nötigen vorsicht
auch für diese festtage wünsche ich mir
dass möglichst viele wieder so vorgehen
um sich um ihre eltern und großeltern
ihre lieben zu schützen mit abstand mit
masken und mit zusätzlichen täglichen
tests auch wenn sie schon zweimal
geimpft sind testen sie sich bitte bevor
sie mit anderen menschen für die
weihnachtsfeiern zusammenkommen
diese pandemie hat uns in den
vergangenen 21 monaten gemeinsam sehr
viel abverlangt deshalb freuen sich
viele zu recht auf diese festtage im
trauten kreis der familie mit der
gebotenen vorsicht unter gewordenen
rücksicht ist das auch möglich
die impfungen sind ein ganz wichtiger
faktor im kampf gegen umgekommen seit
dem 18 november läuft unsere booster
kampagne bis zu 30 millionen impfungen
bis weihnachten habe ich und haben wir
als ziel ausgegeben viel spricht dafür
dass wir dieses ziel erreichen werden
doch corona macht keine weihnachtspause
bei unserer heutigen zusammenkunft haben
wir deshalb entschieden die impfkampagne
mit unverminderter kraft auch während
der feiertage zwischen den jahren und zu
beginn des neuen jahres fortzusetzen
als nächstes wollen wir bis ende januar
weitere 30 millionen booster impfungen
erreichen
damit wären dann drei viertel der
bürgerinnen und bürger drei mal geimpft
und die booster impfung sollen künftig
bereits drei monate nach der zweiten
impfung möglich sein das kann ich hier
sagen wird auch die stiko zu
unterstützen
impfen
bleibt unser ziel damit möglichst viele
vor omikron geschützt sind darunter
verstehe ich nicht nur
auffrischungsimpfungen sondern auch erst
im 5 und 210 von
73,5 prozent der deutschland inzwischen
mindestens eine impfung als nächstes
zwischenziel möchte ich eine impfquote
von mindestens 80 prozent an steuern
wenn wir das erreicht haben müssen wir
das nächste ziel in den blick nehmen
bei aller unsicherheit die es über das
virus nach wie vor gibt wissen wir einst
das risiko für nicht geimpfte erwachsene
sich zu infizieren und schwer zu
erkranken steigt durch die neue variante
noch einmal weiter
deshalb mein appell lassen sie sich
impfen zu den eigenen schutz zum schutz
ihrer lieben und geschätzt von uns allen
wenn sie unsicher sind informieren sie
sich bei ihrem arzt oder ihrer ärztin
bei anderen fachleuten und fragen sie
die vielen die sich bereits haben impfen
lassen fast 60 millionen deutsche sind
inzwischen vollständig geimpft ohne dass
wir von schweren nebenwirkungen oder
langfristigen einschränkungen
ganz anders bei denjenigen die auf den
intensivstationen um ihr leben kämpfen
oder mit den langzeitfolgen der kurve
erkrankungen zu bringen haben
und zu den konkreten maßnahmen die der
bund und die länder heute beschlossen
haben und die spätestens ab dem 28
dezember also gelten
erstens
mit blick auf die ersten erfahrungen mit
omikron in anderen ländern ist zu
erwarten dass die zahl der infektionen
auch bei uns deutlich ansteigen wird
mehr infizierte bedeutet einen erheblich
höheren krankenstand als in jeder
anderen phase dieser pandemie
deshalb fordern wir alle betriebe der
kritischen infrastruktur auf vor allem
feuerwehr polizei rettungsdienste
krankenhäuser die pandemie pläne zu
überarbeiten oder zu aktivieren wie sie
trotz hohen krankenstand der belegschaft
die kern versorgung aufrechterhalten
entsprechende pläne werden so
vorbereitet übrigens auch für
elektrizitätsversorgung andere bereiche
dazu gehören damit sie schnell und
unkompliziert wirken
zweitens
die hatten beschränkung für ungeimpfte
bleiben erhalten 3g am arbeitsplatz das
heißt nur wer geimpft oder gelesen oder
tagesaktuell getestet es darf in seinen
arbeitsplatz gehen oder bus bahn
benutzen
noch strenger ist es im einzelhandel in
kinos und theatern hier haben nur
geimpfte oder genesene zutritt es gilt
also die 2g regel und manchmal zweig
plus und je nach regionalen pandemie
geschehen kann für die geimpften gewesen
eben dieser zusätzliche tests nötig sein
das war mir schon erwähnte zwang leblos
außerdem gelten die strikten auflagen
für private begegnungen von ungeimpften
weiter es sind nur treffen im eigenen
haushalt und mit maximal zwei personen
aus einem anderen haushalt erlaubt das
gilt auch für die weihnachtsfeiertage
ich darf die bürgerinnen und bürger
eindringlich darum bitten sich an diese
regeln zu halten sie sind keine eschen
kamen sondern dienen dem schutz der
nicht geimpften und von uns allen
dritter auf der genesene und vollständig
geimpft werden wieder gewisse
beschränkungen nötig private zukunft
zusammenkünfte sind auf maximal zehn
personen beschränkt das gilt natürlich
insbesondere im hinblick auf silvester
es ist deshalb derzeit nicht mehr die
zeit für partys und gesellige abende in
großer runde kinder unter 14 jahren
werden wir dieser beschränkung auf zehn
personen wie bisher auch für wie gewohnt
nicht einberechnet
vier clubs und diskotheken dann bis auf
weiteres geschlossen um eine verbreitung
des virus zu erschweren auch
überregionale großveranstaltungen dürfen
nicht mehr mit publikum stattfinden das
betrifft insbesondere fußballspielen
um die krankenhäuser zu entlasten haben
wir schon vor einiger zeit beschlossen
dass der verkauf von feuerwerkskörpern
zu silvester verboten wird sie kennen
das bereits aus dem letzten jahren
gleichzeitig wird ein verbot von
ansammlung und versammlung an silvester
und neujahr gelten
meine damen und herren ich hätte ihn
gerne erfreulichere nachrichten kurz vor
den weihnachtsfeiertagen mitgeteilt
diese pandemie strengt uns alle an wir
alle sind nur während der pandemie müde
das hilft aber nichts wir müssen
abermals zusammen stehen und auch in
vielen fällen eben distanz halten
wir müssen uns schützen und unsere
angehörigen
wenn wir das tun mit all der vernunft
die uns als menschen gegeben ist werden
wir auch gut durch die nächste corona
wende kommen
trotz oder gerade wegen all dem wünsche
ich ihnen ihren familienangehörigen eine
besinnliche und schöne weihnachtszeit
und einen guten jahreswechsel
in der ersten woche des neuen jahres
werden wir uns mit den
ministerpräsidenten und
ministerpräsidenten der länder erneut
zusammensetzen um die lage zu bewerten
das treffen wird am 17 dezember
stattfinden kindern
als nächstes wäre herr wüst an der reihe
ja viel herzlichen dank die erste
stellungnahme des expertenrats der
bundesregierung war eine deutliche
warnung dass 19.00 photomatix noch
einmal unterstrichen man spricht von
einer neuen dimension im pandemie
geschehen die omi konnotation ist viel
ansteckender als delta
bundesminister lauterbach hat wurde von
1,5 fach gesprochen und gerade wenn man
nicht gewusst hat ist kann um ikon den
impfschutz teilweise unterlaufen es
drohen deshalb schwerwiegende folgen bei
den infektionszahlen für die belastung
unserer krankenhäuser und für die anzahl
der menschen in quarantäne
es geht deshalb auch um die
aufrechterhaltung unserer kritischen
infrastrukturen wir nehmen den rat
dieses expertengremium sehr sehr ernst
um ecrn mahnt deshalb mehr denn je zur
entschlossenheit zu politischer führung
und zu einem konsequenten und
einheitlichen handeln impfen und
boostern sind unsere stärksten waffen
gegen omikron niemand sollte deshalb mit
seiner oder ihrer impfung warten jeder
und jede sollten sich so schnell wie
möglich boostern lassen wir schaffen in
nordrhein-westfalen aktuell anderthalb
bis zwei millionen impfungen pro woche
und bundesweit werden wir durch das
engagement der kommunen der erste und
alle die dabei mithelfen das ziel von 30
millionen impfdosen bis zum jahresende
mit großer wahrscheinlichkeit erreichen
und die impfkampagne sollte dann so ist
auch die verabredung des heutigen tages
auch darüber hinaus auf hochtouren
weiter laufen an dieser stelle noch
einmal ein ganz herzlicher dank an alle
menschen die das möglich machen sie
leisten einen großen dienst in unserem
land und an ihren mitmenschen wir wollen
bis ende januar so ist die verabredung
weitere 30 millionen impfungen
erreichen und deshalb muss das tempo bei
dieser impfkampagne weiter hoch bleiben
das offroad auftreten der omicron
variante erfordert auch mit zusätzlicher
dringlichkeit die einführung einer
allgemeinen impfpflicht
damalige bundesfinanzminister
vizekanzler heutige kanzler hat im
november
formuliert dass er mit einer umsetzung
im februar rechne bund und länder haben
das im beschluss vom 2 dezember
aufgegriffen das muss geld in die länder
bitten deshalb bundesregierung bundestag
die vorbereitung für die allgemeine
impfpflicht zügig voranzutreiben und
kurzfristig einen zeitplan vorzulegen
auch dieses thema verlangt tempo und
klarheit zum schutz gegen unikum gehört
auch der schutz unserer kritischen
infrastruktur es geht um daseinsvorsorge
und strom und wasserversorgung feuerwehr
polizei und an erster stelle natürlich
um die funktionsfähigkeit unseres
gesundheitswesens
professor krömer vorsitzende des
expertenrates hat heute aus england
berichtet wo ein drittel der
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter in der
kritischen infrastruktur entweder
infiziert ist oder in quarantäne
darauf muss man sich vorbereiten
frühzeitig und planvoll das ist die
verabredung des heutigen tages bund und
länder werden sich deshalb mit den
betreibern der kritischen infrastruktur
sehr eng austauschen dass die pandemie
pläne angepasst werden um vorbereitungen
zu treffen wir müssen gewährleisten dass
die pandemiepläne so funktionieren dass
unser land auch weiterläuft wenn uns das
aus england berichtete hier eher alt zum
schutz gegen nikon empfehlen die
experten eine deutliche reduzierung der
kontakte deswegen haben wir heute ein
ganzes paket von maßnahmen beschlossen
dass der bundeskanzler gerade
vorgestellt wird es deshalb nicht
wiederholen diese maßnahmen sind das
fundament unseres schutz falls gegen
omikron bund und länder brauchen in
dieser lage aber auch darüber hinaus
eine klare strategie für die nächsten
wochen und dazu gehört dass wir uns am
nachmittag des siebten januar erneut
hier treffen werden um über das weitere
vorgehen zu beraten die bundesregierung
hat auf bitten der länder zugesagt eine
konkrete planung vorzulegen wir brauchen
als grundlage für unsere beratungen
anfang januar konkrete vorschläge für
etwaig notwendiger maßnahmen die mit dem
expertenrat abgestimmt sind wir werden
außerdem über gegebenenfalls notwendige
rechtliche änderungen sprechen müssen
und über die anpassung der
wirtschaftlichen hilfsinstrumente für
die betroffenen bereiche
wichtig ist aus meiner sicht
abschließend dass bundesregierung noch
länder bei ihren planungen auch
zukünftig den expertenrat des rk ii
einbezieht das robert koch institut das
ja eine bundesbehörde ist hat heute kurz
vor der mpk empfehlungen vorgelegt die
mit den auffassungen bundesregierung
einigen teilen nicht übereinstimmen und
über die empfehlung des expertenrates
hinausgehen man muss sich ja nicht in
jedem einzelnen punkt die auffassung des
lka teilen aber aus meiner sicht wichtig
dass dem rk ii der respekt
entgegengebracht wird den es verdient
das lka hat mit seiner arbeit in den
letzten monaten der pandemie in
deutschland viele menschenleben gerettet
insgesamt ist heute das signal wichtig
dass bund und länder bei der bekämpfung
von omikron beim schutz der menschen in
unserem land hand in hand arbeiten
die lage ist ernst und deshalb brauchen
wir entschlossenheit konsequenz und ein
gemeinsames vorgehen
vielen dank dann als drittes die
regierende bürgermeister
kinder und männer der monster ich will
betonen dass es glaube ich ein sehr
wichtiges zeichen ist dass diese
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz heute drei
tage vor weihnachten noch einmal
zusammen gekommen ist und auch eine
orientierung gibt für die kommenden
feiertage für das
signal und den wunsch auch an die
bevölkerung das verantwortungsbewusst
diese kommenden feiertag begangen werden
sowohl das weihnachtsfest als auch der
jahreswechsel es geht darum dass wir
eben alle auch wenn wir uns freuen auf
die begegnung mit familien mit freunden
sehr sehr
verantwortungsvoll und überlegen wie
können wir unsere kontakte einschränken
wenn man sich trifft möglichst eben das
schützen das testen das impfen in den
mittelpunkt zu stellen und es ist ganz
klar dass angesichts dieser lage wir
auch uns keine pause erlauben können was
das impfen angeht die impfkampagne muss
auch über die feiertage weiter laufen
mit nur sehr geringen
runter fahrenden aspekten vielleicht am
heiligabend am ersten feiertag aber auch
wir in berlin haben uns natürlich
genauso wie alle anderen bundesländer
ganz klar das ziel gesetzt diese tage
weiter zu nutzen wir sind darauf
angewiesen dass viele dabei mithelfen
sowohl die hausärzte die auch zwischen
den jahren mithelfen beim impfen als
auch unsere impfzentren die mobilen im
teams und auch die kreativen
impfaktionen an besonderen orten gerade
für kinder für jugendliche für familien
es ist wichtig dass wir alle kräfte noch
einmal zusammen dem auch gerade jetzt in
diesen tagen das impfen weiter
voranzubringen das boostern
voranzubringen ich bin sehr froh dass
wir in berlin mittlerweile ein drittel
der berlinerinnen und berliner
gemeistert haben und bei einer impfrate
von fast 75 prozent
sind was die erstimpfung angeht bei den
zweit impfungen auch über die 70 prozent
hinaus natürlich werden wir auch dieses
ziel verfolgen was olaf scholz erwähnt
hat auf die 80 prozent und zu zu bewegen
und beim bus dann noch weiter auszubauen
wir haben heute von bundesminister
lauterbach gehört dass er für eine
verlässliche impfstoff beschaffung
aufsteht ich finde das sehr wichtig dass
er also uns auch in aussicht gestellt
hat dass mindestens zehn millionen
impfdosen
der woche zur verfügung gestellt werden
auch bis in den januar ende januar
hinein diese planung schon heute auch
angekündigt hat das ist sehr wichtig
dass es hier eine verlässlichkeit gibt
auch in bezug auf weitere medikamente
und impfstoffe
die auch neu auf den markt kommen werden
ich finde außerdem wichtig dass wir ein
klares signal für die kinder impfung
setzen das ist ja erst seit wenigen
tagen möglich dass die fünf- bis
elfjährigen auch einen impfstoff
bekommen ich kann aus berlin sagen dass
die impfkampagne sehr gut angelaufen ist
und ich werde auch in meiner ja jetzt
heute beginnenden amtszeit übermorgen
ein auch zusätzliches signal setzen wir
werden im roten rathaus in berlin eine
impfaktion für kinder stattfinden lassen
das ist nur ein teilaspekt aber ich
glaube dass es wichtig ist eben hier
auch nochmal die eltern die familien
anzusprechen und auch mit den mobilen
impf teams in die einrichtung zu gehen
für menschen die behinderung haben für
menschen die in anderer weise nicht so
mobil sind wenn die menschen nicht in
die impfzentren kommen können müssen wir
alles dafür tun dass die impfstoffe eben
zu den menschen kommen können die
schwierigkeiten haben eben die
angebote bei den hausärzten und in
impfzentren wahrzunehmen deswegen muss
es auf drei solide füße gestellt werden
was wir beim impfen tun die impfzentren
auf der einen seite die mobilen im teams
auf der anderen seite und auch eben das
was durch die hausärzte und auch durch
kreative orte des impfens eben
ermöglicht werden kann ich finde sehr
wichtig dass wir auch heute hier ein
signal in richtung wirtschaft gesetzt
haben die überbrückungshilfe 4 die eben
den besonders betroffenen unternehmen
auch noch mal zusätzlich zur seite
gestellt wird die korona schutzmaßnahmen
wie eben bestimmte unternehmen bestimmte
branchen besonders hart treffen es ist
wichtig dass wir das signal von dieser
ministerpräsident konferenz auch ende
des jahres eben setzen das finanzielle
unterstützung weiter zur verfügung
gestellt wird und dass eben die härte
für hilfen inklusive der sonderregelung
für die veranstaltungswirtschaft als
auch der sonderform des bundes für
messen und ausstellungen der sonderfonds
des bundes für kulturveranstaltungen und
das programm corona hilfen im profisport
ist all diese maßnahmen verlängert
werden sollen das ist ein wichtiges
signal für die wirtschaft in unseren
ländern und ein zeichen dass wir eben
jetzt auch in die umsetzung vor ort dann
gehen um eben die länder verantwortung
zu übernehmen damit diese hilfen auch
tatsächlich vor ort ankommen können und
ansonsten es ist ganz klar
weihnachten ist die zeit an dem man in
der wir zusammen kommen mit unseren
familien aber es ist auch in diesem jahr
ganz besonders die zeit der achtsamkeit
der gegenseitigen solidarität
und auch silvester wird eben nicht die
zeit der großen party sein sondern des
verantwortungsvollen umgangs mit dieser
situation und deshalb ein großer apel
kontakte zu reduzieren und andererseits
die haben wir schon viele viele male
gesagt immer wieder können wir es nur
sagen diejenigen die gepustet sind
werden einen besseren schutz auf forum
economy.com haben einen viel besseren
schutz und deswegen der aufruf bitte
nutzen sie all diese angebote und der
dank an all diejenigen die dabei
mithelfen dass auch in den feiertagen
diese aktionen stattfinden und wir den
schutz unserer bevölkerung auch dadurch
verstärken und gewährleisten können in
den vielen dank dann habe ich schon fünf
wortmeldung die erste kristina dunz nd
herr bundeskanzler das
robert-koch-institut hat ja alarmierend
heute
darauf verwiesen dass es sofort maximale
kontakt beschränkungen geben sollten
könnten sie den dissenz zur
bundesregierung
erklären ist dass jetzt mehr panikmache
des lka oder haben sie es einfach nicht
übers herz gebracht den menschen
weihnachten zu verderben und deswegen
kontakt beschränkungen erst ab 28
dezember und an den ministerpräsidenten
und die regierende bürgermeisterin
trocken das abgeordnetenhaus hat heute
die epidemische lage beschlossen sind
sie beide herr wüst und sie der ansicht
dass es ein fehler war dass das
bundesweit ausgelaufen ist und sollte
der bundeskanzler scholz mit der ampel
koalition dies im bund wieder einführen
danke
schön für ihre frage wir haben ja einen
sehr großen fortschritte in unseren
beratungen über die notwendigen
maßnahmen in dem wäre ein expertenrat
eingerichtet haben der sich mit der
frage beschäftigt was zu tun ist die
qualitative verbesserung des
beratungsprozesses der politik liegt
darin dass wir die dort versammelten
experten sechs patenbitten und ein wort
um zu ermitteln aus ihrer diskussion die
sie miteinander führen das hat auch gute
wirkung gehabt sie sehen dass die
vorschläge am sonntagnachmittag
präsentiert worden sind und es hat noch
am sonntag beratung gegeben und den
verschiedenen
gesprächsgruppen von
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten ist hat am montag
intensive beratung gegeben sämtliche
chefs der senats- und
staatskanzleien und der chefinnen der
situation staatskanzleien und es hat
heute nochmal intensive beratung gegeben
so dass wir in kürzester zeit von
gewissermaßen
sonntagabend bis heute nachmittag einen
konsens entwickelt haben über die
schritte die aus diesen empfehlung des
expertengremiums folgen
und diese entscheidung sind ja
einstimmig getroffen worden
einschliesslich der vertreter des lka
dabei dass ich glaube ich ein
fortschritt findet der zusammenarbeit
ansonsten bin ich sehr dankbar für die
arbeit die das r kelly leistet in den
letzten jahren und auch in den nächsten
jahren das sind ja immer wieder neue
vorschläge für unsere politischen
beratung und da werden sicherlich auch
noch viele bekommen was wir jetzt haben
ist
sofortige kontakt beschränkung
und zwar in ergänzung zu denen die wir
schon haben im vergleich zu vielen
anderen ländern um uns herum hat
deutschland weitreichende kontakt
beschränkungen sind relativ frühzeitig
auf den weg gebracht das unterscheidet
uns das wäre zwar für geschäfte von
restaurants hotels zweig plus für viele
bereiche gemacht haben auch für kinos
kulturveranstaltungen alles mögliche ist
sehr beschränkt wir haben das erste mal
3g am arbeitsplatz eingeführt das hatten
wir lange nicht also alle müssen geimpft
sein oder von einer infektion genesen
oder aber sich tagesaktuell getestet
haben wir haben 3g für den öffentlichen
verkehr wir haben weitreichende kosten
trage pflichten wir haben sehr
erhebliche beschränkungen in allen
bereichen durchgesetzt und umgesetzt
einschließlich testens und masken tragen
in den schuhen und diese vielen
maßnahmen haben ihre guten tag gehabt
und auch die setzen wir jetzt noch etwas
obendrauf ich habe die maßnahmen schon
genannten maßnahmen jetzt unmittelbar
greifen das ist die frage der
beschränkung von kontakten den privaten
bereich auch bei
diensten
über das maß hinaus das wir bisher schon
hatten dass es die schließung von clubs
und diskotheken und das ist die maßnahme
den blick auf großveranstaltung die
überregional also sehr verfasste
umsetzung und in dieser linie verstehe
ich auch die empfehlung der von dem
institut bekommen haben
wenn ich anfangen darf soll will ich die
frage gerne sehr klar beantworten wann
wenn nicht jetzt vor uns haben wir eine
epidemische lage nationaler tragweite
insofern ist der beschluss dass sie
nicht fort gelten möge nach meiner sicht
aus meiner sicht ein klarer fehler
also ich würde hier nicht von einem
kleinen fehler sprechen es geht darum
dass die beendigung der lage in einer
anderen lage entschieden worden ist wir
haben seitdem eine entwicklung die dazu
führt dass neue maßnahmen ergriffen
werden müssen diese maßnahmen werden
jetzt ergriffen und es ist wichtig dass
alle maßnahmen die wir ergreifen
verhältnismäßig sind und dass wenn wir
maßnahmen ergreifen uns auch an sehen
inwieweit diese wirksam sind und dann
weitere maßnahmen gegebenenfalls
ergreifen um genau in dieser situation
befinden wir uns jetzt sind heute schon
noch mal zusätzliche schritte
entschieden worden wir werden am siebten
jahr nur wieder zusammenkommen werden
dann auch bewerten inwiefern begonnen
sich entwickelt hat wird werden in
dieser zeit alles dafür tun das
infektionsgeschehen so zu minimieren wie
weit es möglich ist und dann auch
darüber zu beraten haben inwieweit eine
erneute pandemische lage zu entscheiden
ist aber für den heutigen tag und für
die jetzige situation
sind angemessene maßnahmen entschieden
worden jetzt geht es darum die auch
entsprechend umzusetzen und es geht wie
gesagt bei allem was wir tun schon auch
um verhältnismäßigkeit und deswegen wir
haben das ende in einer lage oder ist
darüber entschieden worden
wie anders war als jetzt und bei allem
was wir tun geht es schon darum sich
anzuschauen
welcher situation sind wir und wenn die
situation eben nicht mehr so gravierend
ist dann muss man sich auch wieder über
das zurücknehmen von maßnahmen gedanken
machen jetzt sind wir in einer anderen
lage deswegen ist es gut dass wir heute
diese beschlusslage haben und alles
weitere wird im januar dann sehr zeitnah
auch zu bewerten seien
es nichts das hab ich kirsten becker von
raidl
guten abend herr scholz kurz zwei
verständnisfragen die schließung von
clubs und diskotheken gelten für alle
bundesländer also zum beispiel auch
bremen wo sie ja eigentlich wegen der
insolvenzen weiter offen sind und die
einschränkungen mit den zehn personen im
privaten raum heißt aber übersetzt wenn
ich mit 30 leuten zu silvester feiern
möchte wo ich mir im restaurant einfach
drei separate tischen und das ist dann
möglich und herr wissen eine frau geht
bei
hervis sie haben ja das papier auch
angesprochen hätten sie sich gewünscht
dass genau diese maßnahmen aus dem lkw
papier heute sozusagen geschlossen
worden wären und warum ist das aus ihrer
sicht nicht passiert und frauke weil sie
haben in berlin die epidemische notlage
jahr für berlin heute auch also mich sie
aber der senat erklärt was ist da
sozusagen das einvernehmen auch zwischen
den ländern aber ihre ihrer empfehlung
sollten jetzt alle länder zumindest mal
auf landesebene diese epidemische
notlage aussprechen es haben ja noch
nicht alle getan vielleicht auch noch
mal an herrn wüst
schönen dank für ihre fragen
gleich das ist etwas das neue
wahrgenommen werden muss aber ich möchte
darauf hinweisen behandeln sehr
einvernehmen durch
es gibt einen einvernehmlichen rat des
expertengremiums dass wir neu etabliert
haben es gibt eine schnelle
einvernehmliche beschlusslage der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz wie wenn es
schon zuletzt wir sind ja schon vor
kurzem zusammen gekommen haben unsere
fragen beraten wir haben auch im
november ein sehr weitreichenden
beschluss auf den weg gebracht und den
ich mich sehr bemüht habe und bei dem es
um die frage ging legen wir das
eigentlich hin dass wir eine
beschlussfassung haben bei der mit der
booster kampagne und der impfkampagne
beginnen und das ist das möchte ich
gerne sagen neben der tatsache dass wir
sehr früh weitreichende kontakt
beschränkung maßnahmen insbesondere für
ungeimpfte aber auch für viele weitere
ergriffen haben der qualitative
unterschied zu vielen anderen ländern
deutschland ist strikter vorgegangen im
bereich der kontakt beschränkung als
nicht alle aber die allermeisten anderen
das gleiche gilt für die frage des
bewusstseins das haben wir mit großem
tempo vorangetrieben
sie haben in den letzten tagen und
wochen sehr genau wahrgenommen wie wir
es geschafft haben dass diese kampagne
auch tatsächlich überall in deutschland
stattfindet alle 16 länder haben ihre
fünf zentren wieder eröffnet mobile im
teams aktiviert die ärzte und kassen
haben das impfen mit einer ganz neuen
geschwindigkeit praktiziert und wir
erleben rekord die brauchen wir auch
weil das unsere eine strategie ist im
kampf gegen die korona pandemie dass wir
das impfen und booster den vordergrund
schieben und dabei hast uns sogar etwas
gelungen was wahrscheinlich die
allermeisten fast schon fatalistisch
und zu unrecht
für möglich gehalten hatten nämlich dass
wir auch wieder voran kommen mit den
erst impfung von vielen die sich bisher
noch nicht entschlossen hatten auch dort
sehen wir jetzt wie die zahlen zu nehmen
und das muss auch sein deshalb bin ich
dafür dass wir unser handeln
strukturieren durch ehrgeizige ziele die
dann aber auch dazu führen dass ganz
deutschland sich unter hakt und diese
ziele umsetzt das ehrgeizige ziel 30
millionen impfung ab dem 18 november zu
organisieren bis ungefähr weihnachten
werden wir nach aller voraussicht
erreichen und deshalb machen wir gleich
weiter und sagen die nächsten 30
millionen den wir jetzt im deck wir
machen weiter zwischen den tagen wir
machen weiter im januar und wir wollen
dann in dieser zeit auch die erst-
zweit- dritt- impfung auf den weg
bringen für all diejenigen die bisher
sich noch gar nicht impfen lassen in
diesem monat im nächsten monat im
übernächsten monat weil wir das
hinkriegen müssen dass wir höhere zahlen
erreichen 80 prozent bei dem impfschutz
für alle wollen wir erreichen jetzt
schnell aber wenn wir das ziel erreicht
habe ich wiederhole das nochmal so
weitergehen mit dem nächsten ehrgeizigen
ziel über eine impfpflicht zu
diskutieren und nicht vorher zwischen
ziele zu formulieren die in die richtung
marschieren macht ja keinen sinn also
wenn wir bei 80 prozent sind wird es um
die 90 prozent geben nur damit ich das
schon mal ankündigen wir wollen nicht
beobachter seien der entwicklung in
unserem land sondern tätige tätig sein
und aktivitäten unternehmen das gleiche
gilt im übrigen für die maßnahmen die
sich auf die kritische infrastruktur
richten das ist besonders und
bemerkenswert dass wir das jetzt schon
in den blick nehmen wir erwarten durch
achsprobleme passiert sind sondern für
hypothetische mögliche entwicklung
treffen wir jetzt vorsorge damit all die
bereiche der kritischen infrastruktur
von den elektrizitätswerken bis zu
krankenhäusern polizei feuerwehr und so
weiter in der lage sind ihren betrieb
unvermindert in allen zeiten aufrecht zu
erhalten unter diskutieren wir jetzt
auch über viele folgemaßnahmen die
daraus sortieren und das umsetzen zu
können
übrigens eine gute botschaft in diesem
zusammenhang ist dass jetzt weitere
impfstoffe zugelassen werden die für
diejenigen attraktiv sind die sich mit
den bisherigen nicht haben anfreunden
kann und das wird unsere kampagnen noch
viel mehr zur impfung zu bewegen auch
noch mal neu unterstützen also ich
glaube deutschland geht hier einen
klaren strengen weg und dass wir uns in
ganz kurzer zeit wieder treffen zeigt
dass wir auch einen präzisen plan
verfolgen was wir brauchen ist
koordiniertes handeln ist klarheit und
kopf klarheit dem und das bedeutet auch
dass wir es miteinander machen dass die
zeit vorbei sind der jeden tag jemand
eine neue meldung produziert immer was
zu tun wäre sondern dass wir lieber
schnell uns zusammen diskutieren und
handeln und gemeinsam agieren dass es
geschehen und das ist ein gutes zeichen
denn die zeiten werden nicht einfach ja
wenn ich
dann fertig also wenn ich zum rk ii
eben was gesagt habe dann deshalb weil
nicht der respekt und der schutz der
institution wichtig ist wenn sie die
nachrichten tagsüber verfolgen auch
einzelne zitate die dann das licht der
öffentlichkeit erblickt haben aus
unseren beratungen glaube ich versteht
jeder dass das angezeigt er gewesen ist
ja die informationslage seitens des
bundes im weitesten sinne war chaotisch
und hat auch zu verunsicherungen im
heutigen tage geführt expertenvotum auf
der einen seite rk ii als oberst der
bundesbürger auf der anderen seite das
mag man auch kritisieren aber
die institution deshalb zu kritisieren
wie ich das teilweise
aus
medienberichten enorm habe ist
unangemessen und deswegen habe ich dem
leben für mich klar widersprochen wir
brauchen eine solche institution die uns
an vielen stellen ja auch geholfen hat
in den letzten monaten menschenleben zu
schützen und darum geht ist deswegen
muss ich mir nicht über die ganze zeit
und auch nicht heute jede einzelne
forderung zu eigen machen aber man soll
die institution ernst nehmen auch in
zukunft
das thema länderöffnungsklausel ich habe
jetzt hier nicht die aufgabe anderen
ländern zu sagen was sie tun sollen wie
sie rechtstechnisch ihre dinge
umzusetzen haben sind hier aufgabe des
npd-vorsitzenden wir nordrhein westfalen
haben sie genutzt
dazu es gibt ja eine sehr große klarheit
was zu tun ist über die empfehlung die
einstimmige empfehlung des expertenrates
und diese einstimmige empfehlung ist ja
auch die grundlage für den entschluss
der heute gefasst worden ist ich sehe
nicht dass es da eine unklarheit gibt
sondern es gibt eine klare orientierung
darauf dass man politische beschlüsse
fasst auf der grundlage einer empfehlung
die ein eingesetztes gremium gegeben hat
um hier mit rat und tat zur seite zu
stehen das haben wir gemacht und
deswegen gibt es da eine sehr große
klarheit und ich will mich dem
anschließend was er wisse auch gesagt
hat es geht nicht darum zu sagen jetzt
müssen alle länder genau identisch den
gleichen weg gehen sondern es ist immer
gut wenn es einheitliche
rahmenbedingungen gibt auf die wir uns
verständigt haben heute aber wenn es
auch die möglichkeit gibt dass die
länder eben anhand ihrer regionalen
gegebenheiten anhand ihres regionalen
infektionsgeschehen orientierte
spezifische massnahmen treffen können
und deswegen muss dass jedes bundesland
auch für sich entscheiden ob es eine
solche epidemische lage feststellt
inwieweit die instanzen auch aussehen in
berlin hat das abgeordnetenhaus das
heute bestätigt
und hat eben auf die vorlage der
senatswahl entsprechend auch reagiert
wir haben das so eingestuft und werden
dementsprechend auch heute nach der mpk
beschlussfassung eben diese maßnahmen
noch am donnerstag in der senatssitzung
entsprechend umsetzen in einer neuen
verordnung war das muss immer anhand
auch der jeweiligen infektions lage im
jeweiligen bundesland passieren und das
ist ja auch gut dass es diese
möglichkeit gibt anhand einheitlich
vereinbarter rahmenbedingungen in der
mpk und anhand der konkreten lage vor
ort über die geeigneten
verhältnismäßigen und wirksamen
maßnahmen auch zu entscheiden und ich
will das auch noch mal betonen oder
schutz hat sehr kurz erwähnt wir haben
tatsächlich auch in berlin rekordzahlen
impfen auch bei den erst im fond auch
bei den jugendlichen
65 prozent der 12 bis 17 jährigen die
mittlerweile ihre erste impfung bekommen
haben über die hälfte die zweitimpfung
das sind schon deutliche signale ein
sehr hoher zuspruch beim kinder impfen
wir sehen also es gibt auch gerade bei
den jüngeren bei den eltern bei den
familien wird ein großes interesse durch
die zusätzlichen angebote auch eine
wahrnehmung dieser angebote das ist
genau der richtige weg das geht eben
alles daraufsetzen in verschiedenen
angeboten in verschiedenen möglichkeiten
um die menschen auch dazu zu überzeugen
um entsprechend hier auch diese ziele zu
erreichen und zunächst einmal auch auf
das angebot zu setzen vor eine pflicht
denn oder die nächsten schritte für eine
pflicht auch dann gegangen werden so ich
habe noch fünf fragen habt der
regierenden bürgermeisterin versprochen
dass sie nicht zu spät zur
konstituierenden sitzung ihres senates
kommt insofern länder das so ein
bisschen
kondensieren in den fragen und wo man
kochen in antworten dann kommen wir gut
durch und müssen berlin und nicht
unregierbar machen frau münchen ist die
nächste
guten abend auch von mir herr scholz
herr lauterbach hat vor ziemlich genau
zwei wochen das ziel ausgegeben dass man
zu weihnachten reisen wieder empfehlen
können soll können sie das jetzt mit
gutem gewissen zu tun oder haben sie das
ziel verfehlt und die bundesregierung
redet auch in diesem jahr zu weihnachten
von reisen ab und eine frage an alle
woher nehmen sie die zuversicht dass die
maßnahmen vor allem von den ungeimpften
auch befolgt werden denn viele um
ungeimpfte sind ja grund skeptisch würde
ich sagen was die pandemien
die empfehlung die wir geben stehen dem
beschluss der bundesregierung
so der bundeskanzler zusammen mit den
regierungschefin und regierungschefs der
länder gerade gepasst hat und auf die
konzentrieren wir uns das sind die
kontakte schränken die wir haben und
ansonsten sagen wenn so ein bleibt
vorsichtig insbesondere wenn ihr euch
mit euren freunden zu weihnachten trifft
oder familie beachtet dort halt die
vorsichtigen und steht auch in den text
noch mal wieder das sind die dinge die
wir vorschlagen und nicht andere daneben
sonst hätten wir sie ja in den text und
die vorschläge aufgenommen es sind sehr
weitreichende maßnahmen ist wenn ich
noch mal ausdrücklich dazu sagen haben
sie werden auch dazu beitragen dass wir
weiter vorankommen nochmal alle
maßnahmen die wir ergriffen haben führen
dazu dass wir
gegenwärtig eine verbesserte lage haben
wir sind nur klug beraten zum beispiel
das expertengremium da das lte und viele
andere und wissen aus der sicht auf
andere länder dass es mit omikron noch
mal wieder anders werden wird und wir
uns jetzt nicht trüben lassen dürfen von
der guten entwicklung die wir gerade
sehen und deshalb greifen wir auch die
entscheidende maßnahme die dazu wichtig
ist nämlich immer gut dann alles das was
damit verbunden ist und haben das auch
entsprechend die kraft eingelegt dass
wenn das voranbringen neben den kontakt
beschränkungen neben den maßnahmen zur
kritischen infrastruktur
also dass die maßnahmen natürlich auch
umgesetzt werden müssen ist ja völlig
klar und dann halten muss das einmaleins
sehen wir schauen immer auf die die sich
nicht daran halten aber die allermeisten
halten sich dran jenseits der letzten
details des geschriebenen rechts löst
das was wir tun ja etwas aus bei den
menschen wir sind vorsichtig sie nehmen
rücksicht sie passen sich an die tragen
wieder vermehrt maske das muss man
glaube ich immer wieder unterstreichen
und an für alle anderen adressieren wir
natürlich auch nicht nur appelle sondern
es geht auch kontrolliert an vielen
stellen sind es natürlich nur
stichproben sei denn wir reden von
zugangskontrollen in bestimmten
bereichen wo man natürlich dann besser
kontrollieren kann
nur für mein land sprechen wir
unterstützen die ordnungsbehörden die ja
kommunaler behörden sind auch mit
landesmitteln dass man da mehr machen
kann mit den normalen ausstattung eines
normalen ordnungsamtes wird man das
nicht alles hinkriegen deswegen
unterstützen wir schon länger getan hat
verschiedenen stellen tun das jetzt noch
mal zusätzlich unter auch einen gewissen
kontrolldruck zu haben wir haben auch
die bußgelder erhöht und im grunde ist
es am ende doch wie im straßenverkehr
nicht jeder verstoß wird in jedem moment
geahndet aber doch so oft und durch die
bußgelder auch so spürbar dass sich die
allermeisten menschen dran halten
sind viele noch zu überzeugen und
überzeugen sich gerade ich teile den
pessimismus nicht er sich gelegentlich
verbreitet und ich glaube dass ganz
viele
einfach durch die art ihres lebens nicht
dazu gekommen sind sie keinen weg
gefunden haben andere prioritäten hatten
dass viele auch sorgen hatten was die
verschiedene möglichkeiten betrifft und
natürlich beeindruckt sind von beidem
was wir jetzt erleben letztens den
vielen bürgern und bürgern des landes
die sich schon vollständig haben impfen
lassen sind ja immerhin über 70 prozent
die im vollständigen impfschutz haben es
geht weiter nach oben wir wollen jetzt
die 80 prozent erreichen und dann weit
nach vorne gehen und umgekehrt
ermöglichen ja auch die erfahrung dann
mit der
9 virus bälle noch mal darüber
nachzudenken ob es nicht besser sich
impfen zu lassen und das will ich an
dieser stelle noch einmal mit nachdruck
unterstreichen der nicht geimpft ist ein
risiken
großen
risiko ausgesetzt
infiziert zu werden zu erkranken
möglicherweise schwer und dafür gibt es
dann keinen schubs wenn man sich nicht
hat impfen lassen und dass wir überzeugt
vielleicht die eine oder den anderen
auch noch und deshalb finde ich sollten
wir schon beieinander bleiben und im
übrigen weiß ich auf vielen die sich
bisher nicht anrufen das dass sie sich
trotzdem sehr vorsichtig verhalten weil
sie schon wissen dass corona gefährlich
ist und deshalb bin ich zuversichtlich
dass wir das hinbekommen viele hinter
diesem weg zu versammeln
kirchner von der deutschen welle und
danach 100 jahreswert von herr
bundeskanzler sie haben mehrfach darauf
verwiesen dass deutschland früher
kontakt beschränkungen eingeführt hat
als einige europäischen nachbarn was
sind in deutschland erwartungen an die
europäischen nachbarn jetzt und haben
sie heute in dieser runde oder denkt
deutschland allgemein über neue
maßnahmen im hinblick auf omikron an den
deutschen grenzen nach und dann herrn
wüst die kurze frage wo das ganze zeug
hat von einvernehmlichkeit gesprochen
haben sie das heute auch so empfunden
und frauke fall wenn sie von einer
handlungsgrundlage sprechen meinen sie
damit einen minimalkonsens und wünschen
sie sich dass auch andere bundesländer
so ähnlich wie hamburg maßnahmen früher
einführen als den 28
wir haben über die maske angesprochen
und das regime das zu geschehen hat in
bezug auf nachbarländer ist ja
bekannt es werden gegenseitig viele
unserer nachbarstaaten als hochrisiko
länder eingestuft wegen der entwicklung
dort und das geht immer hin und her wie
das jetzt die ganze zeit noch gegangen
ist was wir haben da ein sehr
etabliertes vorgehen dass wir uns ab
betrachten und natürlich gucken wie die
lage immer wieder neu an verabredet
haben wir heute als pdf geschrieben
haben
ja und das auch gleich mit zu
beantworten und zwar einvernehmlich
sonst wäre es keinen beschluss und schon
auch die terminfindung war
unproblematisch und einvernehmlich und
zügig um das in abgrenzung zu dem was
wir in der jüngeren vergangenheit erlebt
haben auch klar zu unterstreichen
ich kann mich noch einen
ministerpräsidenten
konferenzen erinnern die so waren dass
wir uns denn
irgendwann mitten in der nacht oder am
frühen morgen zur pressekonferenz
versammelt haben dass die tatsache dass
heute diese ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
ja gerade mal zwei stunden gedauert hat
und dann ein fertiger beschlussvorlage
zeigt eigentlich schon wie
einvernehmlich die situation und die
diskussion auch
verlaufen sind und das ist natürlich zu
einzelnen punkten auch gesprächsbedarf
gibt das ist klar aber es war sehr gut
vorbereitet und wir sind jetzt an einer
verständigung die alle umsetzen können
für die kontakt beschränkung ist ja auch
einen spätestens zum 28
dezember vereinbart worden das heißt die
bundesländer können jetzt je nachdem
wann die kabinette auch entsprechend
sagen gegebenenfalls das auch früher
machen aber ich will einfach sagen wir
reden hier wirklich über ganz wenige
tage und wir haben dazwischen eben das
weihnachtsfest und ich glaube es ist
völlig in ordnung dass jetzt in der
umsetzung mit diesem spätestens 28
dezember auch agiert wird und die
bundesländer die möglichkeit haben das
entsprechend auch vor ort umzusetzen
innerhalb der nächsten wenigen tage
verbunden mit den aufrufen an die
bevölkerung ja auch dennoch ihre eigenen
jeweiligen entscheidungen im familiären
umfeld im freundeskreis auch zu treffen
um auch jenseits von verordnungen
erlassen werden durch das signal das
heute durch den beschluss gesetzt worden
ist auch das eigene handeln zu
überdenken und im eigenen umfeld auch
eigene vorsichtsmaßnahmen zu treffen ich
glaube so viel eigenverantwortung und
selbstbestimmt hätten wir wirklich
unserer verantwortungsvollen bevölkerung
auch zutrauen und wie gesagt ich sehe
auch wie viele menschen wirklich auch
sich an die maßnahmen halten und sehr
vorsichtig und sehr verantwortungsvoll
sind und ich finde das muss man auch
sehen und auch denjenigen danken die das
über so viele monate gemacht haben und
all den anderen natürlich durch klare
regeln durch auch kontrollen und
konsequente gegebenenfalls auch
sanktionen etwas entgegensetzen als
nächstes naja ressort von bild und dann
machen
sie haben eingangs gesagt der
bundeskanzler dass sie sich am 17 januar
wieder treffen werden können sie
ausschließen dass es vorher noch meine
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz geben wird
das geschehen der pandemie verlangt dass
wir jederzeit handlungsfähig sind
deshalb kann überhaupt niemanden mit dem
satz was anfangen was man ausschließen
kann das wird ja nicht weiter aber wir
haben sehr genau in den blick genommen
dass wir uns hier zügig treffen müssen
und deshalb auf den siebten januar
geeinigt und das gehört dazu sowohl der
experten
expertengremiums expertenrat als auch
mit wir alle werden über die tage weiter
arbeiten als regierung zusammen mit den
ländern mit allen leuten die wir zu rate
ziehen der krisenstab wird weiter
arbeiten wir werden die impfkampagne
überall weiterführen also da hört jetzt
nicht alles auf und am 17 januar geht es
weiter sondern in der zwischenzeit
beschäftigen wir uns auch noch mit was
anderem aber sehr viel jeden tag egal wo
er sich aufhält mit diesem thema
andreas kienast
herr scholz mit bezug auf das
überraschende auftauchen des papiers vom
robert koch institut heute hat herr wüst
gerade von einer chaotischen
informationslage gesprochen die zu
verunsicherung geführt hat da
interessiert uns natürlich sehen sie das
auch so und sehen sie grund in der
kommunikations leistung des bundes
irgendwas zu verbessern der bund hat
eine sehr gute kommunikation
organisierten expertengremium einberufen
das soll es ratschläge gegeben wird die
haben wir sofort kommuniziert so dass
das denn die beratungen vieler länder
schon am sonntag ein geschlossenes
sicher sehr viel telefoniert
und da mal mit herrn wüst aber nicht nur
mit ihm auch an dem sonntag und dazu
alles beigetragen dass wir aus diesem
schlussfolgerung schnell an
ergebniszielen ich unterstreiche dass
ich die expertise des lkw in den letzten
wochen monaten und den letzten zwei
jahren ganz besonders wichtig gefunden
hat und auch weiter richtig finden werde
und trotzdem bin ich sehr froh dass wir
jetzt genau das gemacht haben was wir
uns
zusammen vorgenommen haben als
gemeinschaft von bundeskanzler und
regierungschefin regierungschefs der
länder nämlich dass wir diesen rat uns
anschauen und dann schnell umsetzen das
glaube ich hat es noch nicht gegeben
dass werden sonntagnachmittag das
ergebnis haben und dienstagnachmittag
die beschlüsse ist schon was
dann habe ich als letzten fragesteller
martin knobbe vom spiegel
der guten abend herr bundeskanzler sehen
sie eine notwendigkeit oder möglichkeit
den gesetzgeber
dazu anzuregen die ihm vielleicht noch
etwas schneller in gang zu setzen also
vielleicht schon im januar oder wollen
sie bewusst diese zeit auch nutzen um zu
sehen ob die wehrpflicht dann überhaupt
noch notwendig ist wenn sich genügend
kämpft haben und an sie alle drei die
frage ob man
ob sie darüber geredet haben dass man
die quarantäne regeln für
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern in der
kritischen infrastruktur vielleicht auf
weichen muss ähnlich wie es in der
ersten welle war dass ärzte mit leichten
symptomen
trotzdem zur arbeit gegangen sind
zunächst mal was man hier sieht
also ja genau ich hatte die zweite frage
beantworte ich zuerst also ja haben
darüber geredet ob die
anpassungen notwendig ist aber wir
wollen uns fachlich beraten lassen
insbesondere srk es darum die frage zu
durchdenken und das ist kein punkt für
schnellschüsse gehört aber zu den
vorbereitung auf eine situation wo es
möglicherweise
viele gibt die
erkrankt sind oder in quarantäne die
keine schweren symptome haben auch zu
hause sind aber am arbeitsplatz film und
was das bedeutet und wie man damit
umgehen kann
wie lange garantien andauern müssen wenn
man sicher weiß dass jemand sich nicht
infiziert hat und ähnliches das muss
fachlich beraten werden da haben wir
alle einen großen respekt ich will das
jedenfalls für mich in anspruch immer
den eindruck das gilt für alle anderen
auch hier das wollen wir nicht einfach
mal so am tisch uns ausdenken da wollen
wir gut beraten sein diesen guten rat
werden wir auch bekommen ich habe in der
frage der impfpflicht michael
positioniert ich bin dafür und deshalb
bin ich auch froh dass sie hier noch mal
wieder auftaucht wir haben hier eine
einrichtungs bezogenen pflicht bereits
etabliert und nein ich bin nicht der
meinung dass wir davon abstand nehmen
sollten wenn wir jetzt
gewissermaßen
weitere fortschritte erzielen sondern
das ist eine diskussion die hier ja
grundsätzlich erforderlich ist und das
will ich ja auch nicht verhehlen damit
das nicht so gerate stattfindet wie
manche debatten dass der letzten zwei
jahre sich zugetragen das ist ja das was
wir durch expertengremium durch schnelle
umsetzung jetzt überwinden wollen
wir
wissen dass wir eine hohe impfquoten
brauchen deshalb müssen wir über 80
kommen und wenn er über 80 gekommen sind
müssen wir über 90 kommen
wir wissen dass wir jetzt nach der
zweiten impfung eine
auffrischungsimpfung brauchen die
booster impfung das wussten wir übrigens
im frühjahr des letzten jahres noch
nicht aber wir wissen ist jetzt seit
einiger zeit und haben uns ja auch
schnell durchgerungen genau das zu
machen und es spricht ja angesichts der
impfstoff entwicklungen viel dafür dass
wir irgendwann im laufe des nächsten
jahres die empfehlung abgeben noch eine
weitere impfung mit geeigneten impfstoff
zu machen klare aussage wenn es
zwischendurch bitte nicht abwarten
sondern die booster impfung hilft jetzt
sofort der schutz vor einer infektion
steigt für diejenigen die zweimal
geimpft sind mit der dritten impfung
sofort in ganz kurzer zeit und schützt
vor krankheit aber auch für davor dass
man ein ansteckend ist und geschützt vor
schweren verläufen nicht
hundertprozentig aber doch so viel dass
das alles sehr sehr wirksam und sehr
empfehlenswertes und genau das wollen
wir tun und gerade deshalb ist die
debatte nicht zu ändern ich glaube auch
dass das schnell gehen muss und die
bundesregierung wird die abgeordneten
dabei unterstützen gute gesetzentwürfe
auf den weg zu bringen und das auch
schnell zu entscheiden würden zu beraten
ich jedenfalls habe mich ja positioniert
und tue es hier noch bei ich halte eine
impfpflicht die dann irgendwann gilt und
umgesetzt werden kann für erforderlich
das wird uns nicht so schnell verlassen
das thema krone
mit blick auf die uhr und die berliner
seine absetzung würde ich diese
pressekonferenz vielleicht gerne
schließen ich bedanke mich für ihr
interesse und ihre geduld und
auch von dieser stelle schon mal frohe
weihnachten vielen dank
ja so weit also die pressekonferenz von
olaf scholz franziska giffey und hendrik
wüst nach dem bund länder treffen alle
drei jahre erst relativ kurz im amt
franziska giffey schiester in dieser
hinsicht den vogel ab heute morgen
ernannt im alarm stadt gleich in die
bund länder konferenz auch der
bundeskanzler ist ja erst wenige tage im
amt hendrik wüst seit 27 oktober
ministerpräsident von nordrhein
westfalen
soweit also diese ministerpräsidenten
und
konferenz mit dem bundeskanzler und ich
bin jetzt verbunden in berlin mit meinem
kollegen gerd joachim von verlor gerd
lassen sie uns zunächst mal noch mal
zusammenfassen was wurde da heute
beschlossen
der bundeskanzler hat es ja am anfang
gesagt der gewicht der wichtigste kampf
ist der kampf um die impfungen es muss
gepustet werden erst dann ist man
einigermaßen geschützt vor dieser
omikron variante und er hat auch noch
mal begründet die tatsache dass im
vergangenen jahr sicher wiesn hat das
die familienfeste zu weihnachten nicht
der pandemie treiber waren sondern dann
die großen partys zu silvester und daran
und an dem expertenrat der 19 experten
vom sonntag hat der bundeskanzler sich
ausgerichtet und die maßnahmen heute
vorgestellt er hat gesagt dass die
pandemiepläne bei der infrastruktur
müssen überarbeitet werden er hat noch
mal gesagt dass gepustet werden muss
ungeimpfte werden nach wie vor das gilt
ja jetzt schon kontakt beschränkungen
haben sie können ja nur noch in
lebensmittelläden und sonst zum beispiel
nicht mal einkaufen gehen und er hat
gesagt nach weihnachten dann ab dem 28
dezember werden auch genesene und
geimpfte
betroffen seien nämlich dann dürfen sich
nur noch zehn personen treffen auch wenn
man genießen oder geimpft ist das ist
eine klare verschärfung bei
fußballspielen darf es zum beispiel kein
publikum mehr geben und bei anderen
großen ereignissen die außerhalb
stattfinden ja und diskotheken und clubs
werden dann auch geschlossen und der
verkauf das war auch schon klar von
feuerwerk wird unterbunden all dies
dient der maßnahme das eben nicht die
großen partys an silvester zum treiber
werden ja vielleicht können wir zum
kontrast aussagen was nicht beschlossen
wurde es würde nicht beschlossen dass
die läden oder die restaurant schließen
müssen es ist auch nicht beschlossen
worden dass schulen schließen müssen
insofern eine ein beschluss der
vielleicht vielen nicht weit genug
gegangen ist
ja das kam ja so ein bisschen raus heute
dieses papier vom rk ii hat alle
überrascht gegen mittag denn da waren
genau diese forderungen drin und das rk
ii sitzt ja in diesem 19 expertenrat der
vor zwei tagen noch seine maßnahmen
denen der bundeskanzler und die
ministerpräsidenten weitgehend gefolgt
sind da sitzt er das lka auch mit drin
und insofern war es schon überraschend
das lka heute schärfere maßnahmen
gefordert habe wenn man ein wenig die
sender verfolgt hat und die aussagen von
anderen epidemiologen die nicht zu
diesen 19 gehören dann kann man ist
schon ein bisschen er verstehen denn die
haben gesagt das reicht ja alles
überhaupt nicht aus was vorher schon
klar war was kommen soll sondern wir
sind zwar im moment in einer phase und
das macht es für die politiker besonders
schwer wo die zahlen tatsächlich in
deutschland leicht zurückgehen hier in
berlin übrigens nicht und eben 100
anderen bundesland nicht allein in toto
in deutschland gehen die zahlen im
moment zurück und dann den menschen zu
erklären wir stehen vor einer ganz
großen pandemie welle
beschränkungen in eurem privatleben
hinzunehmen so wie das vor einem jahr
war das ist sehr sehr schwierig auch den
menschen zu sagen ihr müsst dringend
geimpft werden wenn doch gleich der
bundeskanzler die wissenschaftliche
erkenntnis gleich am anfang wieder
gegeben hat wenn man zweimal geimpft ist
wird man wahrscheinlich trotzdem
erkranken nur der booster hilft das ist
natürlich wenig erfreulich für alle die
die bisher noch nicht oder nur einmal
geimpft sind also das ist schwierig zu
vermitteln und ich finde dass das olaf
scholz ganz gut gelungen ist in dem wir
immer wieder darauf hingewiesen hat dass
boostern ist das ziel wir müssen 30
millionen menschen nicht nur bis
weihnachten übrigens in der
regierungserklärung vor einer woche hat
er noch bis silvester gesagt aber in der
tat das impfen geht in deutschland sehr
gut voran also dass boostern 30
millionen bis weihnachten und 30
millionen dann bis ende januar schaffen
und das ist in der tat der weg den alle
wissenschaftler raten ob man vor
weihnachten schon härtere maßnahmen
hätte ergreifen müssen sei dahin
gestellt die diese kapriole mit dem rrk
ii die ja auch von herrn wüst
angesprochen wurde die war schon sehr
bemerkenswert in dieser pressekonferenz
ja noch mal zur erinnerung was das el
kaida heute morgen gefordert hat
maximale kontakt beschränkungen von
jetzt bis mitte januar das wurde
allgemein so verstanden dass rk ii
fordert einen lock down auch von
restaurants auch von schulen ab sofort
so ist das und umso verwunderlicher war
das rkw wie gesagt in diesem 90er
gremium sitzen den beschluss am sonntag
auch mitgetragen hat das was das rk ii
der heute veröffentlicht hat ist
sicherlich ein papier was dann zum
tragen kommen müsste oder sind maßnahmen
muss ich genau sagen was zum tragen
kommen müsste wenn diese omikron
variante uns wie in dänemark jetzt schon
überrollen würde die frage ist eben kann
man prophylaktisch ist so angehen dass
nikon erst gar nicht so hart zuschlägt
in deutschland der sagt der
bundeskanzler ja aber wir fangen damit
am 28 dezember an und niemand weiß in
diesem moment genau ob das die richtige
taktik ist jedenfalls ist die botschaft
des bundeskanzlers und der
ministerpräsidenten heute klar seid alle
vorsichtig feiert mit euren familien
vorsichtig möglichst nochmal getestet
weihnachten und große silvester sausen
die können wir nicht genehmigen und
werden wir nicht genehmigen ja soweit
eine erste einschätzung von gerd joachim
von voller aus berlin herzlichen dank
und schönen abend und
ich begrüße hier im studio professor
volker kronenberg
politikwissenschaftler hier an der
universität in bonn lassen sie uns
gleich mal an diesem punkt bleiben das
ist ja schon eine gewaltige resonanz
möchte ich mal sagen da gibt es die
fachbehörde die aber untergeordnet ist
dem gesundheitsministerium die empfiehlt
ziemlich unverblümt einen sofortigen
lockdown dann treten die
ministerpräsidenten und der
bundeskanzler zusammen und die
bestehenden einiges aber das ist eben
sehr weit weg von dem was man aus dieser
empfehlung der heraus gelesen hat und
diese rk ii empfehlung gleich schon
ziemlich dramatisch
verstehe ich stimme ihrer wahrnehmung
und einschätzung zu und dann stellt sich
jedoch die frage und das dann an andere
akzente als wir das gerade gehört haben
warum also ich bringe das mal auf das
bild auf mich macht das den eindruck man
will vollgas geben aber gleichzeitig bei
angezogener handbremse also einerseits
sagt man man trug jetzt wahnsinnig viel
und impfen 30 millionen und dann wieder
30 millionen da tut sich was aber warum
man heute zusammengekommen ist dieses
neue gremium am sonntag ist auch der
tatsache geschuldet dass man diese
omikron variante eben nicht sozusagen zu
diesem dramatischen anstieg kommen
lassen will von dem man ja im moment
noch entfernt es kurzum stellt sich doch
die frage warum man dann nicht diese
maßnahmen stichwort rk ii papier jetzt
schon in den blick nimmt bzw sie
beschließt und dann doch wieder abwartet
und zugleich aber sich für anfang januar
wieder verabredet siebter januar wo ja
dann unmittelbar die schulen eigentlich
wieder losgehen wo sich aber alle jetzt
schon fragen wird es denn so sein oder
wird man dann doch in diesen lockdown
gehen ich will darauf hinaus dass dieses
papier natürlich mit mit herrn wieder an
der spitze der eine große autorität in
dieser kona pandemie für sich
reklamieren kann jetzt natürlich doch
diese diese verwunderung diese
irritation erzeugt hat und damit
natürlich dieser
rhetorischen sucht die der bundeskanzler
immer wieder heute bemüht hat doch
einiges genommen hat die fragezeichen
bleiben im raum reicht das wirklich
noch ein weiterer dem fall er
politischer streit war ja auch auf
dieser pressekonferenz zu bemerken dass
die frage war es richtig oder falsch die
epidemische lage zu beenden da haben wir
hendrik wüst gehört von der cdu der die
linie seiner partei vertreten hat es war
völlig falsch die epidemische lage zu
beenden da hat franziska giffey leicht
beschlossener jahr gekonnte und naja das
war ein beschluss aus der damaligen zeit
aber so richtig dagegen argumentieren
konnte die ja auch nicht weil ihr
eigener senat und ihre eigene
landesregierung und das landesparlament
in berlin hat ja heute für berlin die
epidemische lage beschlossen also dieser
streit über die epidemische lage dürfte
jetzt verschärft noch weitergehen dürfte
weitergehen dürfte aber sicherlich viele
bürgerinnen und bürger
letztendlich kalt lassen weil das ist
dann auch die frage das hat es die
rechtliche dimension und wie das jetzt
genannt wird den meisten menschen wird
es darum gehen dass jetzt irgendetwas in
der sache oder eben ein bündel von
maßnahmen ergriffen wird das wirkt was
sicherlich heute wichtig war mir dass
die 16 länder und der bund zusammen
gestanden sind einstimmig einmütig plus
experten-gremium
19.10 das ist sicherlich richtig aber
noch einmal jetzt wird vor omikron
dermaßen gewarnt dass sich doch die
frage aufdrängt ob das was man heute
sozusagen mit einer rhetorik
demonstration der entschlossenheit nicht
mehr der geschlossen hat sondern der
entschlossenheit auf den weg gebracht
hat ob das wirklich reicht denn die
frage ist ja dann wieso denn dann schon
wieder anfang januar und auf der anderen
seite warum sollen denn diese maßnahmen
jetzt erst am 28 dezember greifen hat
das vielleicht doch damit zu tun dass
das was man seitens der neuen
bundesregierung und durch den
bundesgesundheitsminister vor einigen
tagen klar gesagt hat dass man das so
kurzfristig jetzt nicht revidieren
wollte und dieser zweifel der konnte
doch nicht wirklich ausgeräumt werden
und wir haben eine weitere
pressekonferenz vorlegen und das ist die
von marco